we hope good evening everyone welcome
back or good morning or ever you are
these beautiful drinks gentleman will
still deliver all of our equipment just
kidding we're made by Jenna
what is it where's the sangria it's
sangria umm I've never ever had sangria
a day in my life I think I tried
Jackie's like in college my best friend
she's like well let's get sangria and
that is good yeah I was like that looks
nasty dude cuz it was not a red wine
like cheap red wine was like weird fruit
in it yeah well sangria can be bad yeah
yeah okay I'd I never really drank it
but when I was working as a bartender we
had this bin that we kept him with the
fridge for the weekend of sangria and
sometimes it was really bunk and it
tasted nasty but people liked it no this
is obviously incredibly good done yeah
no I
I had just tasted like think really
awful sangria one time when I was like
21 yep that's out there I'm never
drinking that again and then I don't
know what like it's [ __ ] the middle
of December never had sangria a day in
my life yeah and I just got it in my
head that we had a bunch of bottles of
Pinot and as props from your video and
frozen fruit in the freezer and I was
like wait I wonder how you make what's
it called sangria and I went I've looked
it up online and they all called for
like soda and like other [ __ ] but I just
put a bottle of Pinot like dumped some
frozen fruit in there all over ice and
then it put some like orange liqueur and
some raspberry liqueur in there and it
got bomb hmm let me tell you and you
need a little bit of sugar or else that
just tastes like jungle juice like
you're about to go to blackout town it's
very good I think I'm gonna black out
town just because I'm like thirsty and
it tastes so good right it tastes like a
[ __ ] delicious fruit gatoring there's
something beautiful with it's so
refreshing it's beautiful I don't I just
and I don't know what happened that's
like how I remembered your name I met
Julian like months and months before
this happened then one day I woke up in
a dream and I was like oh my god I
remember that kid's name it's Julian
because I couldn't remember your name
yeah and then it came to me I love that
story
mm-hmm uh this is an absolutely perfect
drink for right now it's very nice thank
you for making it well you're so very
welcome I really made it for me but we
made it not for both is there more life
yeah I made a whole jug of it you keep
like a glass of sangria be a good night
you have to make like a jug you have to
commit that's why I was cuz for the
video on Wednesday I needed nine bottles
of Pinot yes you did
and we went to the store I had like two
so we had to buy like seven but it was
still looked like a ridiculous amount of
wine when we checked out and so I was
like you know what if I just take one of
the shitty ones and throw it into a
giant jug you have to use a whole bottle
to make this awesome I was like what am
I like what am I really gonna lose I
have everything to gain everything and
we've gained it that's what I feel like
you know like so this is frozen burg you
just put it right in yeah I mean you're
supposed to use like real fruit so then
you can eat it and they're still great
frozen fruit though because it's almost
like they're ice cubes and also sangria
can get really mushy and gross if the
fruit like yeah like did you ever used
to eat jello that had like pieces of
fruit in it yeah yeah and then all of a
sudden you'd eat when the pieces of
fruit and you're like oh this is [ __ ]
nasty yeah yeah that's what I feel like
sangria would turn into but I feel like
you know when you learn how to bartend
because we've both been bartenders yeah
like uh when you start experimenting on
your own like you learn a bunch of
drinks yeah yeah and then you start
experimenting on your own I feel like
when you're using you know the bars
liquor
you know [ __ ] yell make anything but
then when you actually have to go to the
liquor store and buy all these bottles
of liquor to make something that you
want to make your sort of more careful
exactly
cuz it's on your tab and it's not just
there for disposals alright peaches chew
in the pillow but that's what I felt
like I felt like we literally had a bar
so I was like well I'm nine bottles the
[ __ ] Pinot over here
her yeah hey you guys chill
I know peaches causing ruckus hey peach
peach sorry it's okay it's gonna be okay
Julian's placing all the trials and
tribulations of being a new daddy
she's making you crazy a little bit it's
okay though it's cuz she's gotten to
that age where she can be so naughty
she's gotten very very naughty she she
just goes up on she can get anywhere
which is [ __ ] freaky isn't it [ __ ]
I get anywhere like except for the
counters in the kitchen I think she can
get anywhere that's what when I first
got Kermit I was like you know used to
just having this little glorified
stuffed animal
marbles it was just the sweetest little
like angel that got no trouble ever and
then I got Kermit and I would come home
and he'd be on the dining room table I'm
like what the [ __ ] are you doing like
you're four months old how the [ __ ] did
you get up yeah it's [ __ ] Nadia yeah
they're naughty and no matter how many
times I yell at her she seems to just go
and do it again I know that's like my
niece I was facetiming with my brother
the other day and she's sitting on the
ground and you know she's just like
scooching and crawling and she can sort
of stand up at this point but she's
opening all the drawers in the kitchen
and my brother's just seem like oh no no
no that's not funny like ripped
everything off the Christmas tree at the
bottom she was like crawling around
behind like the power cords he's like
let's get out of there but he said that
she opens up the drawers and then takes
everything out and just like decorates
the house my gosh that's so cute right
for us it's cute for him it's probably
like ah stop
yeah but babies are cute yeah cuz they
do things like oh she cried the first
time I held her she was like really
happy and then I forgot about that
oh man I guess there's nothing more
insulting when someone hands you a baby
and they're perfectly happy you're yeah
and you're like oh and then they're like
yeah we got a violent crime
- oh it's so awful yeah oh my god yeah
where someone's like dog you like I'll
gonna pet you dog and you're and they're
like sure and then you go to pet the dog
like no don't touch me [ __ ] yeah I'm
just here to be your friend meaning I'm
sorry I'm just here to court to you yeah
mmm what did you want to talk about
today drilling well we had mentioned
earlier that the Sony hack situation is
kind of a big deal right now it has kind
of a big deal a little bit interesting
and you well I was I was saying hey like
would you would you want to talk about
the Sony hack and you brought something
up which I thought was even more
interesting which is how it's well we
should get into that we should talk
about the actual Sony chat because there
the hack because I try not to get too
political but I think we can have this
conversation without making it something
completely political yeah I mean I all
the thoughts I have on this and all the
things I want to talk about are not
really political at all well what are
your thoughts on the entire thing mmm I
mean I'm a little conflicted I think
well the idea that a whole entire movie
was made and then it got pulled because
of hackers threats because of you know
country disputes or whatever it is it's
confusing to someone like who's you know
not super informed that's like well you
know I read that it's going to cost him
like 75 million dollars like did no one
really put this up as a possibility of
happening before all that money was
thrown into this movie right well here's
my two cents cuz there was I'm gonna cut
you off bactrim execute the the premise
of the movie that they're going to kill
you know kim jeong-hoon or whatever yeah
uh I think although it has been done
before Team America Kim Jong Il yeah
and all of that although he doesn't die
in that movie he lives on and a lot of
people refer to like North Korea to the
United States is kind of a joke like
I've seen people call it the silliest
and funniest evil dictatorship ever yeah
like I saw people tweet I didn't like by
no means are either of us super informed
so take all of this with a grain of salt
yeah yeah yeah big grain of salt but I
saw that someone had tweeted like
remember the time that Kim Jong Il
kidnapped some South Korean movie stars
because he wanted to make like his own
movies in North Korea yeah I read that
he like tried to produce a like Kim
jong-il like tried to produce a movie
like why am i holding people at gunpoint
like the silliest and funniest evil
dictatorship remember you're talking
with Mikey and Tommy about how they make
some of their cars run uh my would they
like converted oh my god but so anyways
in essence to our culture and country
North Korea is sort of like a joke like
it's so evil and [ __ ] up that it's
laughable
you know stuff that they do absolutely
because it you're just like what the
actual [ __ ] are you guys doing um but
what I think is important especially in
terms of like maybe sometimes what I do
or definitely what professional
comedians do yeah is that you have to
decide at the end of the day if you're
gonna cross a line is the joke worth
worth it yeah is it worth the [ __ ]
the squeeze you don't mean because you
anybody can make jokes about rape
abortion blatantly racist things this I
think would fall into that category when
you're openly like you're not even like
you know changing anybody's name which I
don't think we need to at this point
like that wouldn't have helped anybody's
cause you know is the Kim jong-il and
Kim Jong or whatever I've been such a
joke at this point to Americans yeah
that there's no [ __ ] need to but is
making the entire movie really worth it
is it really gonna be that funny
inspecting you know I say you need to
put ourselves out there and I think a
lot of people who were involved are now
asking themselves that question you know
like was it worth it and honestly to be
truthful with you when you know I'm
getting a little sick of the the Rogen
Franco thing so I wasn't interested in
the movie I saw the trailer house ago I
could take it or leave it I really I
can't say I was either and remember when
this was when everyone just found out
that this was becoming a movie yeah they
were they were getting threats and stuff
yeah before it was even really made
Yeah right I'm sure they were still in
[ __ ] theirs - yeah they were still
yeah um I remember that though I mean
they could have pulled the plug then but
then also just to like build off of what
you just said yeah it's a 75 million
dollar loss or something in the million
dollars of loss yeah but I mean movie
studios take losses like that in the
millions all the time I think Disney or
Pixar whoever put out that last Johnny
Depp movie where who's like on a train
with that face pan [ __ ] oh I think they
lost like 200 million dollar yeah so
it's not like these movie places don't
have [ __ ] companies don't have giant
flops yeah they don't have to so it's
not like a company ending right and this
lyric this was a certainly not company
ending it all but ya know that's what
I'm saying
but that's what I'm saying that what
you're gonna and back into the [ __ ]
creative censorship and all of that like
obviously we we should be allowed we are
allowed in our country to creatively
express ourselves yes which is bad news
that this all happened because now
people are like well what are we gonna
do [ __ ] censor ourselves just like
cuz King John told us we can't see it
now we're not gonna yeah well you know I
feel another reason why I feel
conflicted is I feel like the way that
those threats came early on and then the
how how the movie came out and got made
and also how a little bit grotesque it
was like I saw saw a leaked video it was
like a scene where the Kim jong-un
character dies right I saw that too
where the hell yeah that's grotesque
it's like it's I mean it's slowed down
it's obviously supposed to be like funny
or comedic or whatever there's like a
katy perry cover playing but you know
it's like it's almost it's almost as if
the people behind the movie and the real
brains and the real you know decision
makers thought you know what [ __ ] you
we're gonna really make this movie we're
going to make it like we're going to
make it hard and we're going to really
do exactly what you wanted us not to do
almost as like a big middle finger or a
big like oh you're testing me and not
only did it backfire but like you said
it wasn't worth it
like it wasn't even worth it
it's like there was no message there was
no motive that like people were trying
to you know get this information out are
there any sort of cause to making this
movie other than you know here we want
yeah but I mean it's a it's a slippery
slope because yeah I think we both are
in the boat that maybe the joke wasn't
worth it to make an offensive movie to
some people yeah um you know it needs to
be [ __ ] kick-ass like Team America
was unbelievably good huh and I think
everyone that's all that movie was just
in stitches laughing yeah I mean it was
it was big that's their gimmick I mean
it took people what a decade to
understand that the South Park is
[ __ ] hysterical because people were
too busy being so angry at everything
that they did getting offended
I'm sorry but I mean they did that movie
Team America and there's [ __ ] North
Korea in there this is sort of the he's
the evil plot of that movie yeah but it
was worth all the jokes and most of the
jokes were also making fun of how [ __ ]
up America is this movie's premise was
just like let's go kill him right you
know there's no [ __ ] kill this is no
yeah there's no self satire there's no
making I mean we all know that but
that's what it seemed like you know what
I mean that's the that's the vibe it's
giving off it's a big [ __ ] you to North
Korea for no reason nothing against
James Franco and Seth Rogen but I just
don't think that something that they
sort of created out of their brains
really had the same depth when you think
about it as Team America did because the
thing that made Team America so
beautiful was that they're making fun of
how reckless [ __ ] the United States
is yeah yeah because that's funny right
because we need to laugh at ourselves
also if we're gonna laugh at and also
the the motive behind that joke is like
hey guys our country's a little bit
[ __ ] like the way we act is a little
wrong right we're gonna make it funny
right it's not if I if I were in my
little brain
I'm North Korea like I would feel
offended but I'm like also like alright
well at least you guys know how big of
[ __ ] you are you know
exactly I don't and I think that's why
Team America didn't have any sort of
this reaction even though that was time
it was a dumb it was a different time
and I imagine that this movie because
the entire premise was just go kill the
dictators go kill him it's it's a little
bit you know it's asking for I mean
people are and should be allowed to make
whatever that they want to make at all
ever my complexion and that's that's
tricky because I pulled the [ __ ]
movie so now everyone on the internet is
like oh we bout to [ __ ] whatever but
um do you remember when you told me I
was working I was doing something I
don't remember and Julian came in the
room and was like this before I knew
anything about what was going on that
day Julian was like oh my god did you
hear that they're pulling the movie
because of XY and Z and I was like no I
haven't been on the internet at all
today I'm just over here in my little
cave you remember that yeah the first
thing that I said was because you said
that people had cyber attacked and they
were threatening violence and the first
thing that I said was you know what I'd
rather then pull the [ __ ] movie then
people get hurt over [ __ ] Seth Rogen
and James Franco like I think the bigger
issue is creative expression and our
freedom of speech and that sort of thing
but I my initial thought was like well I
mean come on guys like we don't want
people to actually get hurt yeah it's a
little wreck not that any of the threats
are credible you never know all it takes
is one one real thing that happen and
then suddenly this whole thing becomes
really real right and and I don't think
that they needed to pull the movie and
but I didn't know anything about it at
the time but I think that that that is a
good thought in and of itself is that
like you have to decide if I were a
person that was putting this film out I
would want to decide on my own yeah like
is this even worth me you know I work
that's really hard on this but like I
don't I don't really want other people
to be suffering the ramifications of my
choices over here for the sake of comedy
you know what I mean yeah absolutely if
you were making some really
groundbreaking braking documentary like
[ __ ] yeah yeah I'm fight for it right um
but I think something notable and
similar was the Michael Gallagher when
he put out
the movie smiley a few years ago it was
about the the idea was basically that it
was you know making fun of fortune or
whatever that they would find you and
kill you yeah and so he got hacked and
they threatened everybody his family
they were just doing really [ __ ] up
things leading up to the movie premiere
where they threatened violence and all
kinds of things and we all went to the
movie premiere and just [ __ ] watch
the movie yeah I mean I can't say that I
wasn't like a little bit scared it was a
little bit nervous so yeah that's that's
intense
less intense I mean there's an example
of someone that gets threats and decides
not to negotiate negotiate yeah they're
not terrorists 4chan 4chan is the one
who hacked and threatened is movie
premiere mm-hmm then it's not women come
on it's not some cyber Sony hackers from
North Korea are claiming to be from
North Korea which is what is I think it
is well isn't the definition of
terrorism that it needs to end in some
sort of violence yeah you're right I
guess so I think you hyper solid tears
though but that's why I had a problem
with all these articles being like cyber
terrorism cyber because it's it's like a
oxymoron well as soon as you throw the
[ __ ] T word in there everybody loses
their [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah yeah you know
what I mean that's not what it is I
think it's a hack and I think the people
got carried away with the Angelina Jolie
more harassment that's on it yeah it's
definitely harassment it's definitely
illegal
it shouldn't be tolerated but I think
that we need to remember that you know
it's not like we've been invading North
Korea for forever there's been plenty of
conflicts between not like actual
conflicts but it's not like we're we're
buddies over there between the United
States and North Korea none of which
have ended in like this much attention
yep
you know any me yeah absolutely so I'll
be interested to see where we go I am
true I don't really feel strongly enough
about our ability to make a hysterical
movie about North Korea to then turn it
into some sort of other things yeah I
mean like what other thing I don't know
like have I don't [ __ ] know like
escalating I don't want it to escalate
but that's who you're talking about yeah
I mean people are gonna threaten the
United States for making films about
North
area in a comedic light I think maybe we
could just chill for a little bit it's
like but what so this happened right and
I feel like it's being brought to the
public eye but I feel like you know it's
it's not a hundred percent taken
seriously still like this whole thing
hmm
and like imagine how [ __ ] up it would
be if God forbid knock on wood North
Korea like attacks something in the US I
don't think that they have the actual
well okay I'm just playing complete just
what-if game right now right but imagine
the shitstorm in the White House in the
older generation of America who doesn't
even understand what a hack is right to
have that sort of thing happen like I'd
be pissed
well yeah you're pissed but imagine the
mindfuck like yeah oh my god we made a
movie I read something about some
computer guys getting into our system
and then BOOM like it got real you're
like you like you're questioning what
you even knew as a grown adult in
America like it's and it's not to say
that that's going to happen it's not
going to happen you know most likely
won't happen but it's the fact that it's
even a minuscule possibility or it's
even like a relevant thought right now
is it a little bit crazy and that's what
Sony and James Franco and Seth Rogen
we're thinking is that god forbid
something actually happened we don't
want that and and that's totally
understandable but most people are on
the side of the coin that like we backed
down to terrorists yes what does this
say about America yeah and I read a
couple of articles that were likening it
carefully to other tragedies where like
for example the Boston Marathon bombing
where Boston was shut down afterwards
yes and that gives two terrorists the
idea like if I you know just explode one
bomb and entire city shuts down like
what do you think is gonna happen if I
actually do some real [ __ ] cuz there are
message right but that's that's one
school of thought and the other school
of thought is maybe it's not worth it
I think I'm in the middle a lot of
people are in the middle and a lot of
people are on the other side yeah I'm
I'm I'm just trying to conservatively be
like look guys okay I'm all for freedom
of expression yeah don't think that we
should back down from terrorists but I'm
not sure that I see Sony not playing the
movie as backing down from terrorists I
think I see it as a preventative you
know extreme measure to make sure that
no one ever gets hurt because we wanted
to make something funny yeah you know
yeah I think it's like just a little bit
if that were me making that decision I
would make that call yeah well steal a
car you get you mean you get on down
undoubtedly you get backlash about I
don't know I think that they can put it
online and I think people that people
want to see it's fun yeah I think they
can put it online and I think they can
do all that and I think that that would
make people happy but I I think I would
make the same call if I was in that
position because the idea of anybody
getting hurt on my watch because I
wanted to make some jokes just doesn't
sit well with me yeah no I mean you
can't I mean there were other people
other than you with different moral
compasses than you but I agree with that
yeah and I think that it's it's just
kind of a it's a typical it's a
difficult decision but you put yourself
in it right you know yeah I just think
that people are they want to blame
somebody so they're mad at you know the
guardians of peace or whatever but they
also want to blame Sony for making
America look like a bunch of [ __ ]
yeah I think that they need to shift
their perspective on that decision yeah
I could take those out of it let's just
not backing down
I think are just trying to keep people
safe by any means yeah well because we
didn't really intend for this to happen
and now it's happening so now we're just
doing how often do you get threats from
North Korea for releasing a film it's
not like Sony is well versed in what to
do in this particular so it's very it
seems very foreign especially the way
it's being handled right well I mean
it's an it's a new weird thing I'm
pretty sure that there's people that
have been working there for like 50
years the top executives and stuff like
never had to deal with this a day in my
life
you just got to make a game-time call
yeah you know I just I love I mean I
don't love it's just intriguing to see
the older people a different generation
than
Net Generation deal with the real
ramifications of something based
completely on the Internet hmm like it's
just wild to me oh you mean like the
fact that they were emailing each other
I thought what was funny was that these
people had these like gossipy
mean-spirited sort of like they're
writing everything in an email I've been
hacked
many many times it is not a fun
experience but it's not like I'm putting
[ __ ] you know crazy [ __ ] in an email
like I'm gonna text it to somebody or
but mostly likely I'll just talk to them
and I see them yeah but that's what's
crazy about older people we're talking
about they think like oh it just goes
through the you know hyperspace and then
you don't no one can know legacy they
don't have my password what's this IT
guys what do you mean we got hacked but
we have like secure you know yeah but
when we're talking about this in the car
that I think snapchat is really
important right now because snapchat is
sort of cutting edge in the app world in
having media that [ __ ] disappears
doesn't last forever it's not an
everlasting library okay I mean it's not
that it can't get hacked and it's not
that it can't you know go places other
than where you intended it to you can
take you know a screen shot they can
send it to their friends isn't that but
yeah the fact that matter is once it's
gone it's not lingering around on time
well and you know what another thing is
all it takes is a tweak in their in
their coding and then you can't take a
snapshot mmm snap wait what snapshot
snapshot screenshot wow I just met Oh
cute snip shoot but another like I mean
you're right like snapchat absolutely it
get out of here peach is pioneering that
whole non permanence in social media
like nothing has happened like that
before snaps successfully well
successfully we don't know about that's
why man like there's probably has
happened successfully before snapchats
what I'm saying yes that's not yeah yes
um but it's just it's very interesting
to think about the fact that they took
that risk to do this whole new thing
standout I know it says they didn't get
bought out I kid did not sell out snap
check it yeah oh yeah I know yeah and
then and then the fact that it blew up
like this and it's becoming one of the
most view social networks in the world
that kids got am all [ __ ] vision
absolutely you know why I think I told
you about this you like left at it are
you and Bret laughed at but I was talk I
read this thing about this guy he's an
artist or no he's a photographer
and he takes pictures like from all
around the world and he puts it on his
Instagram and at the end of the year or
at the end of some period of time he's
going he like announce that he's going
to delete those pictures because his
reasoning is because art shouldn't last
forever like art should be not a
permanent thing it should be temporary
it should be appreciated as such and it
reminded me of snapchat what does he
think of the classics and [ __ ] oh Lisa
that's not art go to his Instagram
that's our know but like I just think
it's funny because that opinion of like
when something you know something has a
has a you know it's taking away like you
look at it differently you act around it
differently you appreciate it or not
appreciate it differently than you would
if you usually it's not going anywhere
that is actually a very profound idea to
treat art like you treat life like it's
not always gonna be there and by just
looking at it and then it's always
expecting it to be there is taking it
for great it is taking it for granted
and you look at it it's really beautiful
well I think this guy I commend him I
mean it's like for I'm sure he has
hundreds of thousands of followers on
the answer which is why it's been you
know to his Instagram into oh no I think
it's over I think it's got I think he's
good
though he installed the snapchat bug in
his Instagram so you can't screenshot
his picture I'm just kidding
um what I'm pretty sure when you told me
that the other night my first reaction
was is is he one of those people like a
Native American that believed that is it
native a man I believe what that when
you take a picture it takes a part of
your soul oh I don't know if that's
Native American
what that is because I'd like to know
what they think about videos I don't
think that's the his motive at all I
think whatever I know I know but do you
see the connection that I'm making yeah
it's a similar kind of idea yeah it
takes a face because if if taking a
picture and/or video took away a part of
your soul there are many 13 year olds
that would not be able to get into the
front doors of 7-eleven because they
don't open up if you don't have a soul
okay that Simpsons episode Bart sells
his soul and then the heart won't open
up ya know the entire generation
wouldn't have soul will be all gingers i
I don't actually believe in that idea
but I think that that idea is really
first of all the guy that believes in
the art needing to not last forever is
beautiful I thought that was funny at
first but that's actually a really
[ __ ] I want to look at his Instagram
um but what do you think about the idea
that a picture or a video like some
capture of you in a moment
takes a part of your soul because I
think that that's really [ __ ]
interesting because just think about it
this way think about how much more vein
it makes you when you see yourself in
the form of a picture or a video well if
you're comparing the vanity that's
growing inside of you from looking at
what it was just argumented as
diminishing what you have as your soul
then yeah that mad that math adds up
quiet that math adds up like you say it
takes a part of your soul well does that
mean that vanity is chipping away your
soul yeah it's a fair thought I mean it
is I really think about it in terms of
like vanity gluttony sloth like the
seven deadly sins or whatever I think
that that idea that when you're
recording yourself and taking pictures
of yourself like maybe you're just
chipping away so much of your soul in
terms of vanity that you're just losing
your mind think about how many [ __ ]
actors and actresses are out of their
[ __ ] mind yeah you know what it's not
it's not a far out thought to think
about how much seeing yourself like that
really messes you up in the head well
think about some of the people that
we've met that do like what we do that
have
almost lost their sense of reality like
no sense of reality because of I guess
you know a lot of them are just so I see
myself everywhere I'm loved I'm adored
look at my face right I'm not a person
anymore I'm not a person anymore it's
very interesting that thought
and honestly Xbox no one's talking um I
remember when I was younger and my dad
who now works in the internet space he
works you know in the YouTube I guess
you could say business or the internet
business whatever he would non-stop like
take pictures take videos of us we were
kids doing things
Xbox cancel thank you
but and I was always like so frustrated
by it I didn't know why I just felt like
I and my mom to a little bit but I just
kind of wanted to enjoy what we were
doing and I was a kid and you know even
as a teenager or whatever I would just
be like stop just put it away
we're here I'm fun and now I make you
know I make youtube videos a little time
I'm in your videos I'm in certain you
know he's like I just want to think
about how that switches but your natural
non-social media impaired instinct is to
just be and when you become so saturated
with seeing yourself mmm and absolutely
you know it doesn't make you vain and
per se it doesn't like oh now you're
vain because you see yourself every day
it's it's a you know it makes it easier
to become that way which is why so many
people um yeah I I think I tweeted or
something a couple weeks ago that I find
it difficult constantly to update
everything that I have Instagram Twitter
Facebook [ __ ] buying YouTube and I
think I tweeted something along the
lines of it takes a certain level of
vanity to post a selfie every day that I
just don't have and I just don't have it
I don't have the ability to turn a
camera around to myself and take a
picture of myself and then post it every
single day every something foreign
because I think that you know when I was
growing up there's no such [ __ ] thing
when I was such things teeny
you know we could get on the computer or
whatever but you're not really
conditioned to be me centered you're
conditioned to be like listen child
here's your place in the world now go do
the [ __ ] dishes and you know
what like not like kids these days
aren't though I don't think Noah is a
bigger inflated sense of self it's just
it's just weird to think about because
as much as we grew up with some
technology the kids who are growing up
now with iPhones in their hands from day
one they're being taught a different
normal like a normal day is waking up
checking all your social doing something
checking all your social doing something
else check you know even your non-stop
doing it which is the world that is
everyone's world today so we take part
of that or you know most of the time you
part of that but as a kid when you're
developing and you're learning how to be
a person and you're learning what's good
what's bad what's more what's immoral
and that is just constantly there it's
not even their fault it's just kind of
how their compass is being shaped like
they are becoming kids or people who
think that that's what I mean it doesn't
it I'm not sold that it's necessarily a
bad it's not I'm not saying it is I'm
just saying that's the difference yeah
it's very different yeah for sure but I
also think that it's interesting that
something like snapchat exists because
I'm you know relatively social media
savvy person yeah and I for the life of
me could not understand why the [ __ ] you
would want to disappear and then we
tried it no no I used it for a while to
keep in touch with one of my friends so
I got the premise of it you only mean
but same here once I opened it up to
everybody I was like I was pretty
[ __ ] fun it's pretty fun and then you
check everybody's little [ __ ]
straight it's pretty fun it's pretty fun
because you'd like as you know you're
gonna treat that guy's Instagram
differently
you treat snapchat differently do social
media get very excited you know you got
you know [ __ ] seven seconds and that
[ __ ] and then is going for animal yeah
it's very interesting I mean this
psychology of like how you treat but I
think yeah that that's where technology
is moving it's moving
in the directional antennas like the you
know hopefully we're going to be moving
towards Gmail please like these aren't
going to get saved we have an option to
send things and other dishes as soon as
this person reads this that
motherfucker's gone like they have half
lives exactly yeah or you know all these
text messages and whatever the
government and I'm sure police officers
and people that work in crimes they do
not want that technology to exist
because it assists them in doing a lot
of good work absolutely but [ __ ] wow
it's so weird to think about isn't it
yeah like imagine if like 20 years from
now nothing had permanence on the
Internet like your email like you said
it would disappear in a day no matter
what no coding no hackers could get it
like it was gone the like how we would
treat things mhm and we would just be
you know imagine if we were just content
and living in a world that there was no
permanence on the Internet mm-hmm it's
just wild to think about cuz its yeah
we're really happy cuz you'd finally get
those super bowl pictures off finally
same with Bieber and those pictures that
is people asked for one of those
pictures of me all the internet you know
how the internet works better together
you know ask you asking for - you just
make a whole [ __ ] video scream
Kardashian how the internet works she
knows how they know the weird burn um
yeah no I just I think that there's pros
and cons to it but I mean out of
necessity and out of you know the
transformation of the internet that's
always growing and changing yeah to suit
our needs and wants yeah I think the
trend in technology will continue to be
mobile and will continue to be just not
it's not going to be there forever yeah
because there's plenty of people that
are so frustrated and angry like when I
used to work at the blog people would
write into him all the time like take
this down take it [ __ ] down and
websites all over the place can you
please take this embarrassing pictures
me off the internet or like get rid of
that post it's so nasty it's not true
and then you know someone refuses to
take it down
five years later whether or not the
person's still even running that website
that stuff still on
somewhere it's up there somewhere get
rid of it there's plenty of people that
can't get jobs or you know a Google
search of their name would require them
to do a lot of explaining in order to be
taken seriously and a place that where
they want to work yeah which is
frustrating and sad and annoying that
doesn't go away right now because
there's a lot of people that don't
deserve that you know yeah so I mean
there's pros and cons to it but I think
it would be beneficial to at least have
options like snapchat where we could
communicate without having there be
ramifications of people hacking into
that and looking into it and anything
like that
yeah for general sake of price yeah well
because we know that the [ __ ] anybody
that gets you know what a warrant or
whatever if you were to be doing
something sketchy here the police could
get your phone records yeah yeah let's
[ __ ] that and honestly if this you know
it's not linked people and [ __ ] it's not
gonna be one decision
no president is or whoever is gonna wake
up on a be like no more permanence on
the internet no it's gonna be a slow
process if that happens because nobody
can wake up and say no more permanence
on you know the technology needs the
technology but yeah but I'm saying like
it's a slow process in terms of like a
people getting on board with it if they
even do a great I'm saying it would be
an option yes so you would open your
Gmail Gmail exists like always but what
for a lot of people I want to like yeah
you start something in it you know yeah
but if you wanted to send something it's
enough like a passengered or something
confidential a phone number you could
have an option like open up a little box
this disappears after ten seconds after
this person reads it yeah I'm saying
people want an option yeah I think the
technology will shift so that they have
an option but to take change to just
total like nothing has ever saved it's
not gonna be any time no I'm not saying
that I wasn't saying right you're saying
slow we-well not yeah but just yeah
exactly and also like even in 25 years
the feature gets introduced to Gmail do
you want your emails to disappear after
a day and be gone forever
what's to stop someone from pulling out
their iPhone reading an email taking a
picture of that iPhone like the
technology really has to be able to like
scrambled
via the screen like megapixels you know
anything it's just crazy right but
that's that's that's a technicality of
the idea anybody could take just hear me
out anybody at the present moment can
take a picture of a snapchat or a video
but that's not the idea behind yeah I
get it now yeah dia that we're talking
about is the ability for it to be
terminated and not lingering around in
some snapchat archives it's gone you're
owning yura yura no no that you're right
there's nothing to stop people from
recording things on their own all right
you're right no that makes sense I'm
just like getting caught up in the tech
kappa technically to this but i just
think it would be interesting if we
currently had that technology would the
guardians of disappearing this full
circle would the guardians of peace
still be able to accomplish what they
did yeah it's wild I don't know I'm not
sure that they would it would have no
email hacks you know yeah there wouldn't
no they wouldn't yeah I a lot of people
um I read in Sony like you said had
[ __ ] [ __ ] up emails everywhere and
that's why they're like he'll take a
downturn you know you mean like they're
obeying the hack because there's so much
that they're hiding it's like it's
really interesting to think about when
something like that is introduced that
nothing has permanence what the behavior
of those people are gonna be like mm-hmm
you know like are they gonna be relieved
are they gonna be more reckless like
well it's like when you trust your kid
to go hang out upstairs in their room
with their boyfriend for the first time
do you know what I mean
like yeah I remember when I was this is
a weird analogy but I remember when I
was a teenager or whatever and my mom
was like you guys need to have the
[ __ ] door open like you can't even go
upstairs like yeah and be in a room with
the door closed yeah and then as that
trust grew and it would be like alright
yeah you guys go do whatever yeah like
we really weren't [ __ ] doing anything
bad yeah but it's a toss-up you know you
kind of have to just see how people are
because I think there's plenty of people
that would use that for something that's
fun and good and it
xiety and also look but of course you're
gonna have people cuz every doctor yeah
for every good person there's a bad
person this is better you got it you
gotta treat the whole thing like you're
just about to go let your teenage
daughter go [ __ ] hang out with her
boyfriend for the first time yeah she
could get pregnant or she could just be
playin [ __ ] dominoes in there we
don't know you've gotta trust her that's
true that's how we need to be treated as
a country I assume it's great that we
could get pregnant we didn't playing
[ __ ] dominoes so you don't play
Domino's oh we gonna play Domino's or
not my mom just got me this brand new
Domino set it's definitely an
interesting topic I love talking about
stuff like that because it's a really
like in situations like where now it
makes it real and it's fun to talk about
yeah have you ever been hacked no I
don't think I've ever been personally
exact I mean I think well everyone gets
this where they're like they wake up and
someone's like yo check your email you
sent out a [ __ ] spam email today yeah
that's not really hacked
that's just whatever no um but no I've
never been hacked the whole idea is very
frightening but I've been hacked my my
mobile me has been hacked yeah do you
remember that yeah I do it right like
basically everything's in your [ __ ]
mobile me yeah and uh my facebook got
hacked yeah and it's really invasive but
what made me I never got my mobile me
back which no one gives a [ __ ] about at
this point but what made me really happy
was the first time I got hacked was
right after I had my how to trick people
into thinking you're good-looking video
so the idea of that was just never in
the realm of anything I should ever be
worried about that don't I mean and then
one day I just couldn't log in I
couldn't reach her you my password like
all my security questions had changed
yeah everything had changed and I was
like oh [ __ ] so I think I'm almost
positive I went on like Twitter or some
other social media that I had at the
time and I was like hey can you get like
give me my [ __ ] Facebook back like
it's been real and congratulations but
like come on Dave can I have a back and
they gave it back to me oh my god it's
not awesome
it's just crazy I think somebody just
wanted to get in there and [ __ ] dig
around and then be like yeah did it
and then you know well that was fun they
just gave it back which I really
appreciate it
that's wild man but it's good for you
for asking nicely
it feels very invasive dude I mean it
sucks and uh miserable experience God
you start to worry you're like oh my god
what's on there [ __ ] well yeah that's
what everyone thinks and most people
aren't doing weird discussing shady
things but like everyone's always like
oh my god what's in there like I don't
want everyone to see my stuff because
it's just a level of privacy that's
yours yeah yes well people all up in my
[ __ ] business man I don't either
get the [ __ ] out well so I can't imagine
how these people at Sony felt because
you know you get hacked and some guy
looks at [ __ ] pictures of you
whatever that's something isn't it Sony
gets hacked and it's [ __ ] [ __ ] the
fan whose question mark
Angelina Jolie is a brat and that's news
question Mike I mean part of the problem
is us as consumers of media yeah that
provider or not yeah we made us work
yeah we make these things in it yeah
well I don't know it's an interesting
topic if you guys have any thoughts on
the Sony hack obviously let us know
because we love you know reading what we
missed and yeah and I do know that my
opinion on you know pulling the movie
was I would probably do that too I know
that that opinion is not popular at the
present moment and unpopular opinion
often and I want you to understand when
I say that if I were in Sony shoes I
would pull it but I wouldn't want it to
the point of that by saying that is that
I wouldn't perceive it as backing down
to terrorism I would perceive it as I
thinking a safety measure yeah I don't
ever want to harm someone else cuz I
wanted to make a joke absolutely yeah
which is smart
it's it's a feel like that's the right
way right call even though though I boot
I'm not gonna agree with any decisions
made leading up to this point because
it's just so weird to me it's [ __ ]
weird the whole thing is whole thing's
weird like North Korea what are you guys
doing over there and like it's wrong
were logs into your cars and it's not
like I don't know man I don't know a
million a million billion people want to
see that movie now that they can't of
course cuz that's how you work you want
you can't have but I'm sorry not even
shy really wants well no I'm sorry I
watched that trailer and I'm like okay
nah I don't want to see it it's not
funny it's not worth it if I like when I
knew it was gonna be them - in the
trailer I kind of knew what I was gonna
expect from the movie but it still could
have been great like it could have
looked great no it looked just whatever
I'll take you to leave with the jokes
that they had in trans I don't you know
whatever okay yeah like hey guys I have
this really hysterical movie idea
it's about abortion and it's super funny
and awesome and like the girl gets raped
but it's hysterical and like I can't
wait to make it you guys want to fund it
and then someone's like yeah dude
[ __ ] okay freedom speech you make
what you want to make Jenna and then all
of a sudden people are put your name on
that all of a sudden people are angry
and I'm like we well I'm just try me ya
know I guess I'd whether or not it's
worth yeah that's not what it's not
worth it people it's not worth it plus
just I [ __ ] again I respect Seth
Rogen and James Franco and I like them
very much but hasn't this movie already
been made better than they were ever
gonna make it and I'm Eric what are you
doing this is there's so little to gain
here not a particularly original idea in
the first place so [ __ ] why if you
guys are just like genuinely jacked up
to see this movie I'm sorry but I don't
get it
I'm sorry man please please try min with
you chime in in the comments we'll read
your comments we love reading the
comments and uh yeah there's an
interesting conversation tonight I like
this one yeah hopefully nothing happens
from the Sony hack hopefully we can all
just kind of move along with our lives
and Sony can take a little hit yeah and
also please if you're listening and
commenting be respectable to each other
and don't take anything too seriously
because
this I mean that's a good point for the
present moment all that affects us
personally is that we can't see a movie
better put in perspective I mean the
larger ramifications are on our freedom
of speech and creative expression
etcetera think about what you got and
what you could not anyway thank you guys
for watching and listening and joining
us tonight we will be back next week I
hope you guys are having a great holiday
hope you're with your loved ones you
will be watching this right before
Christmas ready for business and then be
back next week before New Year's so
double holiday podcast well hold it
Pompeii's love you guys and we'll see
you again next week bye bye we don't
know each other